If I don't have headphones on I'm not working and if I'm going to wear headphones all day
I want the best headphones in the world and those are the Hi-Fi man [Hd6]
So what's good about these is first of all well first of all they're open they're open backed
So if you play music the entire world will hear a tinny version of your music pretty loudly
So if you are if you're working in an office with other people you can't wear open headphones
Please don't please don't be that person and that includes everything from great. Oh, sorry great
[oh] people, but if you're working in an office alone, you can do open and boy the sound quality is amazing
[what] do you listen to I'm sorry [I] listen to fish
mostly fish lots of fish I have
Days worth of fish this is most of their albums and every live show they've played since
2009 what I like about them is that they are pretty consistent the music
Just I like the music to begin with and they [release] every every concert they do and they tour a lot every concert
They do they release it on their website, and you can buy it for like 10 bucks
So that's where all this came from and so [it's] like getting a [new] album from the band
You like like 10 times a year or more it's it's great
[so] they so then I can [well] I'm working I can put one of these shows on. I don't I don't do shuffle
I just play straight through I can put one of these shows on and
Then I don't have to think about my [music] for the next 36 days. Tell me about your keyboard. This is the Microsoft sculpt ergonomic
Desktop Keyboard Microsoft yeah, the Microsoft makes the best organ on keyboards they have for years
If not ever they really you know if you want the kind of split design
Basically in my first few [years] of working sorry, but the dirtiness
[I'd] in my first few years of working professionally as a programmer my Sarah develops wrist Soreness
And I was afraid of RSI issues
And so I made a couple of minor changes biggest one was I switched to a split keyboard
And I haven't that was 10 years ago, and I haven't [have] any problem since just normal yeah. Yeah, it rest
Oh, no, you can't. I mean that's kind of [subtle] my elbow on this sometimes. That's why it's all crunched up
I'll often sit like this. I can if I'm thinking about a problem or if I'm browsing something online. It's nice and comfortable there
It's kind of spongy bullet-time. Yeah, it's like a little like you know it's it's you know. It's a fake leather Pad
You know it's fine, and you mouse there you got normal normal mouse. Yeah the apple Magic mouse nothing special
I like the inertial scrolling on it. Yeah, and a piece of gold or something there. That's [it's] on
Yeah, it's this crappy teflon Pad that just it makes it glide really easily as a dolt. It's just a sheet of teflon
So it's yeah
I don't know it's I order from some crazy internet supplier for like 10 bucks at some point in the past look
Pops is up high Hubs
Temporarily oh hey goes good boy. So you what evil computer you running here. This is the 5k imac
From last year, it's the [one-year] old model, and I love it. It's the best computer. I've ever owned by far
Absolutely love it. It's fast the screen is gorgeous. It's huge everything. I want I'm editing podcasts
I'll have like Adobe audition running or logic than what I'm doing
Probably logic actually and then most of the time if I'm doing overcast work, then I'll have xcode running
And then this is the ios simulator running here, and so when you're making ios apps
Apple gives you this little simulated window here, so you can actually run the whole app right here in a window
And it's it's just like just like having a little iphone on your computer, so it's great
so
Over here is all the source code, and there's this giant list of all the all the files this isn't even all of them
It's overcast as a lot of files and a lot of lines of code
[because] this is one file over here
You can see how long it is and this is granted a pretty important one a pretty big one
But what does that want to do? This is the main streaming player?
this is how the streaming player works of like you know getting the data from the source and putting it through the decoder and
Decoding mp3s into sound decoding you know M4a ETC and then being able to stream it without having the whole file downloaded
So that's all that's this is part of that this isn't even all that is part of that
They're really there any two things you need to make a cool app. You just need those two things
That's it really basically
I mean you can you can go into you know?
Graphical programs to make the assets for it to make the icons and so it's stuff like that
But most of the work is right here
It's xcode [and] a simulator that's most of the work and there was things like service and let's sort of stuff
What do you need for that?
It depends. I [mean] you need like a terminal window basically you need like terminals - I always have terminals running
you know terminals running here and
You know monitoring your stuff, but most apps don't even need servers anymore. [you] know for the most part people don't really use
Most apps except for like you know big web services those will use servers of course
But I don't think a lot of people use servers anymore. This is basically audio stuff
So this is a headphone amp. This is it's by a company called shit
yes, and
on there
It's well. This is their logo it's
Sch iit. Okay, right, but it is pronounced shit
So this is my shit headphone amp and this is the Dac
I'm still not entirely sure I believe in audiophile [dax], but I got one anyway just in case
And then over on this side. I have my
Podcasting setup. So I have my podcasting microphone the [noi] [minh] [Kms]. 105 a shit word
Yes, use the uSB filter. I have [a] whining dog and
this is my my microphone interface the USB Pre -
On top of a Mac mini home server and a blu-Ray reader for some reason
I bought the blu-ray reader thinking about be ripping all my movies and [converted] them so I could watch them
You know on an ass and watch on [my] apple TV and in practice
I have not done [that] because it's a pain in the butt. I am not a hard worker. I do a lot
But I [don't] have I don't have a lot of consistency in my hours
[I] don't have a ton of discipline like when when or where I do things
I just kind of do things whenever I can and whenever I'm up to it
And I have to kind of tackle problems
With that in mind so like I won't tackle a problem that requires
Constant input from me or you know tons of dedicated scheduling or tons of other people [to] be involved
I don't hire other people
I don't have any employees because I would be a terrible manager of other employees
And I would probably do less work than them and that would be weird
[I] generally just do what I can with my one slacker self
Are you a good model in should people think that's the way to do or you [you're] terrible role model
All I've done I mean I did terribly in school and everything like all I've done is found a way
That I can take my slacker self and earn a living [I] have no idea it will work for other people
and
That's on a screen called nitpicky details every time I do things like this
[I] think it's a risk and I think maybe it'll turn off some people and every time I work
But no one really notices my job. I look back on it kind of the way. I look back on college. It's like it's something